[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day want to
see a video of a sheriff lassoing a
rainbow unicorn we've got one okay so
what we have here the Chisago County
sheriff's we're driving along and they
spotted this one of the biggest floaties
I've ever seen they laughs at them and
pull them to safety I don't think
they're really in danger I think just
the water was like a little I want to
say icky that's crazy
we've all been there anyone ever been a
situation like you when I sailboat I
camp and we went like a mile and a half
too deep and like none of us know how to
sail so yeah so we made like the girl we
like police swim back she did it she
swam a mile and a half did that make you
like her anymore no no she got someone
to get like a dinghy and to melisten
gosh yeah she's kind of the hero what I
like she's too stupid like she lives a
very happy probably winning triathlons
instead
I could swim a mile and a half so you're
welcome
you said you've been in one like I got
stuck on a mountain and had to get
rescued
stuck on a mountain for ten hours I've
had to get rescued yeah what does it
mean to be stuck on a mountain like I
didn't know how to get down the trail I
thought you were like a cow because cows
can't go that's a cute thing about me
yeah I can't go down stairs like Blair
Witch Project it was very creepy
mm-hmm sounds creepy and I talked about
the town like throw a celebration for
you the next day because it was such a
big deal that you're sure there's a
breakfast for us people were there with
you just me and my husband and our two
dogs and it was our honey wood we've
also got a story about some public
urinals from Paris we're to try to
combat people urinating in public they
put out these eco-friendly urinals
Ainslie there's like a photo of it this
is from a local Parisian Nicolas Moreau
is trying one so they're very they're an
eyesore people are complaining about
them they're bright red they have this
big sign can someone who speaks French
pronounce that you're at wrote what are
you know you read urinal versus urine on
I guess there's one right in front of
the
so there's a guy the cartoon man this is
like the most terrible thing I've ever
seen just put a phone booth there and
let people piss in there this one's
supposed to combat a smell there's just
make a loop that flushes and you're fine
I like this idea and I see the blinders
or something there's like he's right
there this makes me mad cuz it's like oh
let's figure out a way to let men pee in
public but like women who breastfeed are
still shame because that's a lot more
graphic did like the breastfeeding is
good for breastfeeding they need to get
a little baby phone booth and just stick
the baby in there everytime open a phone
booth it smells like piss people are
pissing in there anyway just let's go
with that what about women can they use
this where y'all see it just like I
think you just need to women like a
glory hole situation where you stick all
the way through the hole I don't think
you know what a glory hole
a trashcan rectangle or is it a
recycling circle do you know the answer
I do not wrap up this discussion with
one more story this comes to us from
Australia where a nun from Missouri was
trying to smuggle in two pounds of
cocaine in high heels and she got caught
we have a photo from the Australian
Border Patrol there's a whole lot of
cocaine packed into that high heel and
also just a nun wearing high heels it's
pretty suspicious they made it seem like
because it was like she was Dubai I was
actually kind of sad this is Anil you
know what I mean like this is like I'm
saying that like he dipped her online
like she went through multiple stages
like it wasn't like a surprise attack
what do you mean evaluate Oh a surprise
I'm just saying yeah I just don't know
what this would be the lies Anil duping
to understand the ball thanks for going
this is not a surprise she like waits in
multiple places and like I feel like she
was tricked and the fact maybe she was
like in love but also his name is like
Cornelius Hendrik Cornelius
I feel really bad for this nun but there
were many red flags yeah I just realized
something like I love my cousin's you
need those people around in case you get
stuck a mile and a half on the overlay
[Laughter]
this is what it's for me okay they
should have the best mind oh this is
about the Oscars yesterday we asked what
category should you should they add for
the Oscars and he said they should have
a best mine Buch movie to this day are
not fully understood like how I don't
fully understand shutter island' or why
I get hard for Hannah compliment but I
take them where I can thanks for leaving
a comment up next we've got Joe Mackey
and Sam Laura what's up everybody I'm
here with Joe Mackey and Sam Morril
right before they go head to head
tonight at 10:00 9:00 central and Comedy
Central's roast battle but right now
they're going head to head on this that
or the other so the setup of the game
basically is that there's three
categories something can either be a
prescription drug a piece of Ikea
furniture or a Thai politician I'm going
to say a word and one of you is going to
guess whether that word is one of those
it's a prescription drug he's gonna know
it okay he's got problems
that's your job ah it's HIPPA I don't
want to talk about that
okay so first person to I guess we'll
say three points is gonna win a special
prize but don't worry there's a
consolation prize too so the first word
up Jen loga I'm not gonna hack like I
know Thai politics so I'm gonna go with
Thai politics I'm sorry that's
prescription yeah of course he does look
at him okay Jo your word how long Thai
politics and I'm gonna guess that
because it sounds like it'd be easy to
put together if it was a too easy for
IKEA too easy for a key yeah it is a
prescription drug Wow yeah for what what
is this worth that one is for it's an
ointment that Sam would know the
ointments this guy's got a lot of bumps
on his own
jiminee suppositories he knows those
yeah it's probably get some of those out
or just use the furniture so far no
one's got a point yet so we're gonna
change the game to first person they get
to right wins the prize couch isn't that
comfortable
do you want to sit on this pillow now
yeah you do now fancy let's go what do
you got
the next word ruck Tocqueville I'm gonna
stick with tie politician it was a tie
politician that's one point Sam okay
good next word is arstan that is a
prescription drug that's a wall lamp
Sam for the win your coffee
I'm going tide politician again that's
gonna be a prescription drug come on
yeah that's for something called post
policy thei Mia Vera I know what that is
I don't know what that is either
right it's better than pre your question
your word is big stab IKEA furniture
that's right that'sa the cabinet it's
all tied up son of a bitch
next point wins Sam's turn Sam mm-hmm
Elle Varley a prescription drug that's a
that's a no it's a shelving unit Jo
makuu D it's a tie politician Mackie
wings I gave it away
that's huge Mackie wins and you know
what we got a special prize over the way
like what if his download cards cuz no
one wants to buy that Jo you win these
very special season 4 of a previously
opened DVD of mind of Mencia uncensored
and Sam you're not going home without
anything you when the consolation prize
yeah okay well then it's even worth even
less half of his jokes are on here it
feels perfect half a joke and the
consolation prize a $5 yes I'm much less
than that I should have lost
there you have it chose the winner make
sure to check out Sam's our special this
September 14th on Comedy Central Amy
Schumer presents Sam Morril positive
influence most women to know they look
at sex like buying a car you like can I
see myself in this long-term most guys
know they look at sex like Park in a car
were like they're just fun
and ecat hope no one sees this epiphany
a moment we had suddenly become
conscious of something that is very
important in the Fresh Prince of bel-air
if Will Smith to go uberx
from West Philly to bel-air it would
cost like 3700 hours that was an
epiphany in history this weekend we were
flying back and I got like pulled aside
for like an extra security check they
had me like funds in my suitcase and
like wipe my hands down and I was like I
have nothing to hide right but all of a
sudden I was panicking and I was like um
just act natural yeah those situations
like make you freak out and I was like
I'm here for business but also for
pleasure we'll see you next time on
every damn day
[Music]